anybody born in America who was born
with two parents hit the lottery twice
that's right a black kid who's poor with
Mom and Dad in the house will have a
better outcome than a middle class white
kid with just a mom wow and the surprise
me but the number one issue in America
is the epidemic of fatherlessness 70 of
black kids today you know the world
without a father in the home married to
the mother up from 25 back in 1965. now
25 of white kids into the world without
a father in the home married to the
mother and 65 is important because
that's when a guy named Daniel Patrick
Moynihan he was then the assistant
Secretary of Labor wrote A booklet for
his boss called The Negro family a case
for National Action at the time 25 as I
mentioned the black kids were born
outside of wedlock which he thought was
horrific and we needed to do something
about it now it's almost three times
that and what we've done with the
welfare estate is incentivize women to
marry the government and incentivize men
to abandon their financial and more
responsibility